♪ ♪
>> Greg: YOU REMEMBER FRIDAY
NIGHT’S DEMOCRATIC DEBATE?
YEAH, ME NEITHER.
THE HIGH POINT, THIS QUESTION.
>> IS ANYBODY ELSE ON THE STAGE
CONCERNED ABOUT HAVING A
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST ATOP THE
DEMOCRATIC TICKET?
>> I AM NOT.
>> Greg: AMY KLOBUCHAR WAS THE
ONLY ONE WHO RAISED HER HAND.
WE DON’T COUNT BERNIE, SAYS
SOMETHING GOOD ABOUT HER AND
FRIGHTENING ABOUT THE REST.
SHE THINKS FOR HERSELF AS THE
REST COWER BEFORE THE FRINGE.
THE SAD THING ABOUT THIS CROP,
THEY ARE GRATEFUL FOR EVEN A
GRAIN OF COMMON SENSE.
VOICING DISGUST OF AN
IDEOLOGICAL MENACE THAT HELPED
KILL MILLIONS IS NOW AN ACT OF
BLASPHEMY.
ANYWAY, WHAT A MESS.
MAYOR PETE IS A THESAURUS
WITHOUT SPECIFICS.
LIZ WARREN IS AN INVASIVE PHONY.
JOE SOUNDED LIKE THE GUY AT THE
BAR AFTER HE GOT FIRED, TALKING
ABOUT THE STUFF THAT HE DID
BETTER THAN EVERYBODY ELSE.
IT’S BAD WHEN DEMS SAY THEY
WOULD NOT KILL A TERRORIST.
WHO ARE THEY WORRIED ABOUT
PASSING OFF?
OTHER TERRORISTS, THEY SEEM --
JUST PEOPLE, LACKING ECONOMIC
SKILLS, DEMOCRATS THINK
COMPANIES ARE SINISTER ENGINES
RUN BY THE MONOPOLY GUY AND A
TOP HAT.
PLEAD FOR HER UNANIMOUSLY WHILE
SLAMMING BOOKS WHO WANT EXAMPLES
OF AMERICAN POPULARITY AS THE
ECONOMY MOVES ON WITH WAVES OF
SATISFACTION AND THEY ACCUSE
HALF THE COUNTRY OF EXPLOITING
THE OTHER HALF.
NO REASONABLE DEMOCRAT BECOMES
THE FRINGE.
AS OTHERS PARENT THE LINE THAT
AMERICA IS RACIST THROUGH AND
THROUGH WHICH LEADS TO DIVISIVE
FACTIONS AND PUNITIVE ACTIONS.
REAL PROBLEMS WITH RACE THAT
PUTS FUTURE PROBLEMS IN
JEOPARDY.
HOW DO YOU MEASURE CHANGE WHEN
YOU REJECT ITS EXISTENCE?
AMY IS AT LEAST ROOTED IN SOME
REALITY, WHICH MEANS SHE IS
TOAST.
YOU, JESSE, HAD AN INTERESTING
PERCEPTION ABOUT AMY.
WE BOTH THINK THAT SHE MIGHT BE
THE SURPRISE.
>> Jesse: YES, I THINK SHE
WILL DO WELL TOMORROW.
AND SHE COULD BEAT SLEEPY JOE.
SHE IS RIGHT AT HIS HEELS RIGHT
NOW.
SO SHE COULD REALLY PUT THE NAIL
IN THE COFFIN FOR JOE.
I THINK SHE IS THE ONLY ONE THAT
REALLY SHOWS LIKE SHE WANTS IT.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE THIS
NOMINATION.
BARACK OBAMA TOOK IT FROM
HILLARY.
TRUMP TOOK IT FROM JED, THEY ARE
SERVING UP THESE QUESTIONS ABOUT
SOCIALISM ON A SILVER PLATTER
AND EVERYBODY IS LOOKING AROUND
AT THEIR SHOES.
THESE GUYS HAVE TO WANT IT.
BUT I DO GET THE SENSE THAT
SOCIALISM NOW IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS TOO BIG TO
BEAT.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PUT IT IN A CORNER ANYMORE AND
PRETEND IT DOES NOT EXIST AND
PAY IT LIP SERVICE.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
PEACE WITH BERNIE, WITH THE
SOCIALIST FACTION AT THE
CONVENTION, BECAUSE THERE IS A
GOOD CHANCE THAT HE CAN WIND UP
WITH THE MOST DELEGATES AT THE
CONVENTION.
AND THEY ONLY HAVE THEMSELVES TO
BLAME WAS SOCIALISM.
THEY HAVE ABANDONED THE
MIDDLE-CLASS WORKERS.
AND A LOT OF DEMOCRATIC ELITES
WENT HARD IN WITH THE LOBBYISTS
WENT HARD IN WITH WALL STREET
AND DID NOT DELIVER THE GOODS
FOR AVERAGE WORKING CLASS
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AT THIS POINT IF YOU HAVE
BERNIE, A SOCIALIST AT THE TOP
OF THE TICKET WHO WANTS A BOSTON
BOMBER FROM PRESIDENT, ONCE OPEN
BORDERS AND TO DISMANTLING
WALL STREET.
WHO WANTS TO REVOLUTIONIZE THE
CAPITAL SYSTEM AND DO AWAY WITH
THE INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE,
WHEN YOU FACED OFF AGAINST TRUMP
WITH SOMEONE LIKE THAT ARE
FACING A 40-STATE LANDSLIDE.
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO RECKON WITH.
>> Greg: DANA, I WANT TO PLAY
YOU SOME SOUND ON TAPE OF CHRIS
MATTHEWS, WOULD YOU LIKE TO HEAR
IT?
>> Dana: PLEASE.
>> Greg: LETS WORLD THAT FOR
DANA.
>> I’VE SEEN WHAT SOCIALISM IS
LIKE, I DON’T LIKE IT.
IT DOES NOT FREAKING WORK.
IT JUST DOES NOT WORK.
>> Greg: THE THING IS, DIDN’T
HE PLAY SOME ROLE IN THIS?
HE IS A GUY WHO ATE A LARGE CAKE
EVERY DAY FOR 30 YEARS AND THEN
WOKE UP AND REALIZE THEY NEED A
CRANE TO GET THEM OUT OF BED.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: I THINK HE IS
SOUNDING THE ALARM BECAUSE HE
DOESN’T REMEMBER WHAT IT WAS
LIKE.
AND HE REMEMBERS WATCHING
RONALD REAGAN WHO STAYED AGAINST
SOCIALISM AND HOW THAT FELT A
GENERATION OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
PROCAPITALIST AND PRO-AMERICA.
AND I THINK THAT HE NEEDS TO
REALIZE THAT PEOPLE IN AMERICA
STILL EXIST.
BERNIE SANDERS IS RIGHT, NO
MATTER WHO THE NOMINEE IS, THEY
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO RECKON WITH
THE ISSUE AND PROBABLY BE
LABELED AS A SOCIALIST, MAYBE
NOT DIRECTLY BY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BUT THAT WILL BE THE MESSAGE
FROM THE SUPPORTERS.
AND THEY WILL HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO DEAL WITH IT.
THIS ALSO FALLS ALONG
GENERATIONAL LINES.
THESE POLLS THAT CAME OUT TODAY
SHOWS THAT BERNIE SANDERS HAS A
REALLY GOOD GRIP ON THE YOUTH.
YOUNGER PEOPLE.
AND SOMEBODY LIKE A BIDEN HAS
THE OLDER PEOPLE, BECAUSE A
SOCIALISM ISSUE IS NOT JUST
ABOUT TEMPERAMENT.
IT WAS ALSO ABOUT THE ISSUES.
>> Greg: BIDEN DOES HAVE A
GOOD GRIP ON YOUNGER PEOPLE, BUT
NOT THE WAY HE SHOULD.
KATIE, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
IS IT OVERBLOWN?
>> Katie: NO, I DON’T.
PEOPLE SEVERELY UNDERESTIMATE
THE SOCIALISM MESSAGE THAT IS
BASED ON LIES PAID I HAVE A
T-SHIRT THAT SAYS SOCIALISM
COMMUNISM KILLED 100,000 PEOPLE
AND ALL I HAVE IS THIS T-SHIRT.
YOUNGER PEOPLE CANNOT DEFINE IT.
AND BY THE DEMOCRATS NOT
STANDING UP AND SAYING YES, I
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT ON THE
STAGE PROVES THAT THERE ARE NO
MODERATES IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEY
DESERVE THE LABEL OF BEING
SOCIALIST.
AND BERNIE SANDERS HAS A
QUESTION ON MSNBC AFTER CHRIS
MATTHEWS SAID THAT, IS HE LIKE A
DENMARK SOCIALIST OR A CUBAN
COMMUNIST?
IF YOU GO BACK AND LISTEN TO
BERNIE SANDERS OWN WORDS ABOUT
CUBAN COMMUNISM, HE WAS EXCITED
ABOUT FIDEL CASTRO WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MURDER OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
HEHE SAID THAT REDLINES IN
NICARAGUA WERE A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
HOW THE ECONOMY WORKS.
SO WHEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
POLICY HERE, THESE ARE JUST
DIFFERENCES IN MINOR POLICIES,
THE USER ABOUT TWO COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT STRUCTURES FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE COUNTRY AND IT
SHOULD NOT BE UNDERESTIMATED
CONSIDERING HOW MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE FALLING FOR THE
MESSAGING PROJECT >> Greg: I
HAVE A THEORY ABOUT
AMY KLOBUCHAR, I THINK SHE MIGHT
BE TRUMP’S
TOUGHEST CHALLENGE, BECAUSE IF
CANDIDATES WERE A
MOUNTAIN YOU HAVE TO CLIMB, IT’S
HARD TO FIND THE NOOKS AND
CRANNIES ON KLOBUCHAR THAT YOU
CAN CALL THIS WARREN POCAHONTAS,
YOU CAN CALL BIDEN OLD AND FRAIL
AND BERNIE SOCIALIST, BUT WHAT
DO YOU CALL HER?
NOTHING.
>> Juan: I’M SURE HE WILL COME
UP WITH SOMETHING FOR IT HE IS
GOOD AT NICKNAMES AND BULLYING
PEOPLE.
I JUST WATCH YOU GUYS, AND I
THINK, WAIT A MINUTE.
THESE GUYS ARE SO PRO BURNING,
BUT NOW ANTI-BERNIE.
AND I THINK THAT THEY SEE BERNIE
AS REALLY COMING ON, RIGHT?
BUT LET ME SAY WITH REGARDS TO
BERNIE AND THIS COMMUNISM, WHICH
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE IS A
COMMUNIST.
THE SOCIALIST THING IS JUST
WACKY.
HE IS NOT FOR HAVING THE
GOVERNMENT CONTROLLED THE MEANS
OF PRODUCTION IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Dana: BUT HE IS ACTUALLY.
>> Juan: WHAT BERNIE IS
TALKING ABOUT AND BY THE WAY,
MOST DEMOCRATS SUPPORT, IS THE
IDEA THAT YOU NEED A STRONGER
SOCIAL SAFETY NET IN THIS
COUNTRY TO DEAL WITH
HEALTH CARE.
TO DEAL WITH THE HIGH COST --
>> Jesse: THAT IS NOT A SAFETY
NET, JUAN.
>> Juan: HOLD ON, LET ME
FINISH.
THE HIGH COST OF EDUCATION,
ESPECIALLY COLLEGE EDUCATION
DEBT IS SUCH A PROBLEM FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
NOT ONLY THAT, YOU HAVE SO MANY
ISSUES THAT ALREADY, WE ARE SO
CALLED SOCIALIST ON.
IF YOU WANT TO GO AT
SOCIAL SECURITY.
I KNOW THE PRESIDENT SAID TO HIS
BIG RICH FRIENDS IN DALLAS, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
MEDICARE.
THAT IS SOCIALISM.
THAT’S BECAUSE WE ARE CARING
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Katie: AND ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS ARE GOING BROKE, JUAN.
>> Juan: YOU GUYS JUST GO ON
AND ON THEM WILL LET ME TALK.
>> Greg: YOUR OWN ALL DAY.
>> Juan: THIS IS AMERICA
CARING ABOUT ITS PEOPLE, THAT’S
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING --
>> Jesse: WE ARE CARING ABOUT
YOUR PEOPLE, JUAN.
THE BREAD LINES AREN’T
COMPASSIONATE.
>> Juan: IT IS NOT BREAD
LINES, THIS IS FAIR WAGES
INSTEAD OF GIVING TAX CUTS TO